il me semble qu'il est possible
de définir et d'appliquer la stratégie
d'un grand établissement comme le nôtre
en ayant une expertise interne
stratégique
mais en
n'ayant pas besoin
d'avoir des conseils stratégiques de
grands cabinets anglo-saxons ou
français en revanche je pense qu'il est
impossible à l'état actuel
d'être efficace et je ne pense pas que
ça soit
comme moi je le fais sans que ça me pose
deux problèmes de pouvoir avoir sur des
points ponctuelle des
éclairages de d'experts je citais le
patrimoine immobilier comme on gère les
logements on n'a pas une équipe
spécialiste de cela et c'est tout à fait
utile de voir des des cabinets de
conseil qui ont travaillé avec d'autres
bailleurs etc qui peuvent nous apporter
cela pour des prestations
limitez technique et
suivent puis il ya cette question
notamment dans les systèmes
d'information
de cette sous traitance importante à
dd et des grandes sociétés en général
françaises ou internationales mais
autant française qu internationale pour
lequel il est extrêmement compliqué de
tout internaliser dans les conditions de
deux de fonctionnement à tel point qu'on
s'est
posé la question
de savoir si on n'avait pas intérêt à
créer une sorte de filiale informatique
de l'assistance publique
qui soit une filiale on a une petite
filiale qui est il affiche
internationale
et il ya quelques années on sait c'était
avant le colis dont on n'a pas à
réactiver cette réflexion d ailleurs si
on n'avait pas intérêt à voir une
filiale permettant d'avoir des
conditions de fonctionnement plus souple
pour pour pour l'informatique pas ce qui
est extrêmement compliqué dans un
établissement public à caractère
administratif de se passer de sous
traitants
[Musique]